dans ce livre il y a beaucoup de choses
ils parlent des différentes victimes
présumées de PPDA il parle également des
références qu'il fait dans ses livres il
parle aussi d'un carnet noir qu'il
aurait tenu avec le nom de ses victimes
présumées et leur adresse donc il y a
énormément énormément de choses dans ce
dans ce livre qui est censé sortir
demain alors il sort demain parce que
les spectateurs
juste je vous explique au départ en fait
donc c'est ce livre qui était aux
éditions fayards enfin les éditions
fayards ont reçu hier à une assignation
référé d'une d'une victime présumée de
PPDA qui s'appelle Justine de charme qui
a notamment parlé dans Mediapart qui a
expliqué qu'elle avait été violée en
1995 alors qu'elle avait 19 ans elle est
elle était journaliste à l'époque et
donc elle n'est pas rentrée dans le
détail sur son viol quand elle a parlé à
Mediapart elle expliquait même
d'ailleurs qu'elle avait envie de de
disparaître et que c'était très
difficile pour elle de de parler et donc
elle a reproché en fait à ce livre Le
livre noir de Romain Verley que de
donner les détails de son audition de
son audition en mars 2021 une audition
qui a une pensée garder secrète et en
tout cas témoignage sur son viol avec
des détails assez assez glauques qu'elle
pensait réserver juste à la justice
d'accord alors
pas de souci
dans le monde
et sur Médiapart dans le live de
Mediapart et son nom était donc c'est ça
en fait qu'elle reproche c'est d'avoir
donné les détails de ce de cette
audition et de et de soviol ou
effectivement elle raconte des choses
assez intimes alors il y a des victimes
donc qui ont écrit un mail à l'auteur ce
mail a été publié dans Le Parisien vous
vous êtes autorisé à relater nos
histoires d'humiliation les plus intimes
que certaines d'entre nous avaient
choisi de réserver à la justice vous
n'avez pas respecté notre volonté
rajoutant une nouvelle couche de
violence à la violence nous sommes
pourtant nombreuses à avoir confié à vos
confrères et concerne les viols et les
agressions que nous avons subi il était
inutile de forcer celle qui redoutait
l'impact du récit détaillé de leur viol
sur leurs proches leurs compagnon ou
leurs enfants ça n'apporte rien à la
démonstration c'est blessant alors oui
effectivement elles sont elles toutes
les les les les vaffabes qu'on a vu
notamment dans le reportage de Mediapart
qui se sont unis dans un dans un dans
une espèce d'association me too on écrit
conjointement pour soutenir
Justine de charme et le leur dire que et
dire à l'auteur que effectivement elle
regrettait de ne pas avoir pu
s'expliquer avec lui qui avait certains
détails qu'elle n'avait pas envie de
dévoiler à la presse malheureusement
pour elle c'est tombé il y a à peine il
y a à peine une heure le juge pardon le
livre va paraître demain ça aurait été
une catastrophe s'il paraissait pas pour
pour la maison d'édition parce que le
juge a notamment alors je vous donne le
terme exact notamment estimé que c'était
une information susceptible d'être
nécessaire pour nourrir un débat
d'intérêt général donc finalement c'est
c'est souvent ce qu'on a aussi dans la
presse people quand on fait des
révélations quand c'est d'intérêt public
d'intérêt général la justice nous donne
raison d'avoir révélé certains
fait et notamment des auditions même si
ça peut effectivement choquer les
téléspectateurs ou d'autres personnes
surprenant verlier donc l'auteur se
défend pour lui n'a fait que son travail
de journaliste je ne suis ni le
porte-parole des plaignantes ni
l'avocate PPD là je suis là pour donner
des faits et l'excellente éditrice
Isabelle s'apportable l'embrassea on
peut comprendre l'angoisse de la
dépossession que peuvent ressentir les
victimes qui ont eu beaucoup de courage
à porter plainte personne a été outée
car la femme dont on parle était sur le
plateau de Mediapart on nous divulgue
pas des témoignages par voyeurisme et
pour dénoncer un système un modus
opérandit voilà donc c'était la réponse
de Isabelle il faut savoir c'est que
quand même la vidéo Mediapart a été vu
plus d'un virgule 7 millions de fois
donc effectivement c'est victime ne sont
plus présumées ne sont plus ne sont plus
anonymes voilà c'est dans le livre les
révélations comme on vous l'a dit
on apprend donc comme vous l'avez dit
que PPDA avait un carnet noir avec un
nombre incalculable de prénoms féminins
dedans associés à une adresse et un code
dans son enquête aussi le journaliste
fait aussi le lien entre la fit PPDA
Solène anorexique est décédé en 95 et
plusieurs victimes présumées de PPDA qui
souffrait d'anorexie c'est ce qui est
assez terrible parce que il y a le livre
de autobiographie de PPDA les femmes de
ma vie où il y a des passages qui sont
effectivement à la limite de l'inceste
où il parle de sa fille Solène et du
fait qu'il l'a vu dans la salle de bain
avec les seins pointant etc et ce qui
était est-ce que raconte romain verlais
dans son livre c'est que il était très
attiré il y avait une espèce de de pas
dire attiré par les femmes anorexiques
ou en tout cas vierge et que il y a une
qui est décrit par l'une des des
plaignantes où on l'aurait lui aurait
fait l'amour alors qu'elle m'aime
souffrait d'anorexie juste en dessous du
tableau du portrait de la grande photo
de soleil dans son bureau et en dessous
voilà l'une d'elles décrit un viol sous
la grande photo de soleil sa fille qui
est accrochée dans le bureau de pédiatre
15 jours après sa mort on apprend aussi
on a la réponse sur la relation entre
les deux stars du JT Claire Chazal et
PPDA le journaliste s'explique que leur
relation était toxique dans une
interview parisien où il donne quelques
éléments de son livre apparaître il dit
ils ont eu un enfant dont ils ont caché
l'identité du père tout le monde est au
courant TF1 mais il ne fallait pas que
ça sache c'était risible oui c'est ça
qui est assez c'est que tout le monde à
TF1 savait que Claire Chazal et PPDA
avait une relation mais Claire Chazal
refusait catégoriquement déjà parce que
PPDA était marié quand même le rappeler
que cette relation soit révélée et puis
surtout que que l'enfant qu'elle avait
eu avec lui soit connu parce que
effectivement cette relation que PPDA
est claire Chazal avait été assez
toxique enfin d'une manière générale les
relations féminines enfin des relations
que PPDA entretient avec les femmes sont
décrites de façon générale de façon
plutôt pardon voilà toxique alors il
s'appelle François ce fils il est né en
95 et le petit garçon n'a été reconnu
publiquement par son père que 10 ans
plus tard en 2005 enfin il révèle et je
dénonce je précise juste que Pierre
Chazal n'avait pas du tout du tout idée
de ce que faisait ce PPDA d'accord
enfin il révèle les dénoncent encore
l'omerta qui règne autour de PPDA je
connais beaucoup d'anciens TF1 qui
m'envoient des SMS mais qui reste
planqué la société ne veut pas s'emparer
de la faire ppdara car elle nous dérange
tous ce silence le contribue pas à ce
que d'autres femmes se fasse connaître
en quelque sorte le silence des anciens
protège PPDA c'est ce qu'il dit bah oui
de toute façon sur cette histoire depuis
le départ hein parce que il y a
certaines plaignantes qui se sont à la
direction de TF1 à l'époque et la
direction de TF1 n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas
réagi mais ce qui est ce qu'il explique
en plus c'est que lui-même a reçu des
témoignages et les gens lui ont envoyé
ensuite des textures en lui disant si
jamais tu me cite je te tue tellement
voilà c'est c'est une
omerta sur cette histoire même encore
aujourd'hui à leur PPDA n'est plus la
star de TF1 on continue de protéger de
de protéger l'animateur du JT de la
première chaîne d'accord merci Myriam en
tout cas et ce livre sortira demain oui
Mathieu tu voulais rajouter non j'avais
juste une question c'est que pour
l'instant il est accusé enfin il a été
codé de rien donc de deux choses l'une
soit il est pas condamné et ce bouquin
est horrible pour lui soit il a vraiment
fait tout ça et c'est dégueulasse qu'il
soit encore qui soit encore liberté dans
la rue mais dans les deux cas il y a
quelque chose
sur la plupart des plaintes qui ont été
déposées il y a 16 il y a cette femme
qui ont déposé plainte avec cette cette
plain notamment pour viol et agressions
sexuelle il n'y en a qu'une qui a été
retenue pour l'instant c'est celle de
Florence Portel sur des faits de 2009 le
juge au départ quand elle a porté
plainte à décider que il n'y avait pas
assez d'éléments pour pour voilà pour
faire un procès à PPDA sauf que Florence
Portel c'est porté partie civile et
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une enquête qui
est faite par un juge d'instruction et
que tous les témoignages de ces femmes
viennent remplir le dossier
je crois que pour les viols non 10 ans
il faut dire que
l'enquête continue justement le livre va
aider l'enquête sur l'affaire du modus
opéraniste un système PPDA et ce qui a
un caractère sérieux toujours les mêmes
victimes toujours le même process c'est
ça les enquêteurs sont très intéressants
pour ça